Speaker 1: This feels like yet another one of
those stories, and it is another one. It's not
the same one from before. It's a different story.
There is now a Volusia County, Florida, councilman
who has been ridiculing Dr. Fauci, who is
now hospitalized with very serious covid.
This is Fred Lowri. OK, Volusia County Councilman
Fred Lowry is hospitalized with covid quote. He
is in the hospital wrestling with covid-19. He's
pretty darn sick, Councilwoman Billy Wheeler added
in the afternoon. Wheeler told the News Journal
that Lowery was hospitalized Monday after being
treated with monoclonal antibodies last Friday.
Quote, He has been sick for around two weeks
and got the antibody treatment last Friday,
went to the emergency room late last night.
Brewer said Lowry had double pneumonia, but added
doctors were hopeful he'd come home Thursday.
He had pneumonia a couple of years
ago. His lungs are already pretty beat.
Lowery, a 67 year old Republican, is
midway through his second four year term.
He attracted controversy this summer
for promoting conspiracy theories,
including some about the coronavirus pandemic.
In a sermon at Deltona Lakes Baptist Church.
Politics and religion very intertwined in
Volusia County. We did not have a pandemic,
folks. We were allowed lied to, Lowry said on
May 30th. He referred to Dr. Fauci as Dr. Falsey,
I did not mispronounce that, he said that's the
way I wanted to say it. He labeled Foushee a liar
and a pervert. He also took issue with, by the
way, pervert. Is that even being alleged? He
also took issue with media coverage of the covid
treatment hydroxy chloroquine. It's funny to call
it a covert treatment, because what we figured out
is it's not actually a covert treatment and media
coverage of the theory that coronavirus originated
in a human lab. Larry missed last week's special
meeting. He last attended a meeting on August
17th. And we just lost the article. It's back.
Lourey last preached in a sermon live streamed
August twenty nine. Pastor Bill Hicks gave the
sermon Sunday acknowledging Lowery and many other
churchgoers were absent, then turning to the
subject of the pandemic. Some of you may have been
told Masser mandatory. They are not. We're trying
to take precautions as best as possible, but that
was mis information. You know, this is further
proof that not believing in something doesn't
mean it doesn't have an effect on you. You can
not believe in gravity and you will still be bound
by the effects of gravity on earth, period. And of
this sort of reminds me a little bit, actually, of
this is a nice historical note. This reminds me of
the story of ignores Semmelweis. Semmelweis was a
Hungarian doctor and he was kind of like an early
pioneer of antiseptic procedures on the basis of
starting to understand the germ theory. There's
these invisible things that we can get rid of with
antiseptic practices and cleaning. And lots of
people at the time just slammed him. They couldn't
accept at the time when Semmelweis would say
washing, hygiene, these things will save lives
in medical settings. A lot of people didn't
want to accept that at the time. And it turns
out, whether you believed Semmelweis or not,
you were bound by the reality
that he was right about germs.
If you were going from patient to patient
without washing hands or sanitizing or whatever,
didn't matter if you believed in it or not, it was
going to have an effect on the patients. And it's
sort of a similar situation with covid and it's
similar with simply just the way gravity works.
So I take no pleasure in this. But yet another
covid denier who has been hospitalized with covid
was in theory going to be released yesterday. We
don't know if he was will follow up if we get more
information. We have a fantastic program for you
today. Let me know what you would like covered
next week by sending me a tweet at Pakman. You're
following me on Twitter, right? We'll take a quick
break and be back right after this. Remember that
the David Pakman show is funded mostly by viewers
and listeners who sign up at Join Pakman dot
com, you get access to the daily bonus show as a
member, as well as a commercial free audio feed
of the show, a commercial free video feed of the
show and so many other things.
Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom.